do you believe the accolades you're
getting for your Tonight Show broadcast
from your home people are loving it
they love lighters really cute fun shots
I love when one of your daughters put
like play-doh on your nose and you're
doing half the show with the play-doh on
but they're cute and it's been really
interesting doing it but I figured I had
to do something you know I didn't know
what what the plan was or how long we're
gonna be home and I you know I was
talking to Nancy and I was like look my
wife and I was like I gotta figure out
something because we did our last show
in NBC on was it March 12th I wanna say
right and we have marginal audience and
that's when I came out here just to my
house into quarantine but there was no
plan NBC cancelled the next show on
Friday because we wanted to send
everyone home people are worried they
were concerned didn't know what to do
and they didn't know what this thing was
or how long it's gonna last I said go
home if you feel weird if you work from
home great if not we'll cover for you
but I don't know what this is right
because I think this most similar I've
been to sometimes situation like this
was 9/11 that I lived through right yeah
when I was on seront live and 9/11
happened it was just a bizarre time it's
just so weird and I kind of feel that
same weirdness now and I I remember
looking to my like the late-night guys
to see what they're taking is on and
Alma Ben I remember watching Letterman
and he was behind his desk I'd remember
this and he said that there's only one
I'm paraphrasing there's only one
requirement in any of us and that is to
be courageous
he's like courage defines all human
behavior and he said I've been around
long enough and I think that pretending
to be courageous as just as good as the
real thing
yeah that's great look at you yeah and
her memory is insane that you remember
what people say like that I like that
because he was out there kind of doing
his show with nothing like we didn't
know what to say or do can we laugh can
we do anything you know so I said we got
to do something
and so I call
a zoomed all my producers I go what's
the plan I gotta do something I bought a
tripod today from TC Richards I don't
know why but I'm gonna do something I'm
gonna put on the show and you know I
figured we have everyone comes you know
has me in their household every night
why not bring him into my home and see
what we do I don't know if it's funny I
don't know what is something so I enter
and I even like being in your home I
like seeing that house you built I've
been to the room where Jimmy is in now
and there's even like a slide that you
go down it's wild a lemonade stand and
he sits there like it's his desk it's
great for days to color in by the end
the kids didn't you want to color
anymore just be a massive color but I
mean it makes a great place to film The
Tonight Show actually it really does but
in your wildest dreams could you even
imagine you built that house to be
totally the set of The Tonight Show
it's crazy Tina Fey the other day she
was I love that little you were doing
the other night there's a phone in there
and a pink wallpaper ago my wife built
that she put a real working rotary
telephone in there sure this would be
great for people to call people make
calls I go that'll never happen and Tina
goes and now you're mayor you're filming
The Tonight Show there how long you
think this thing's gonna look like could
you keep this up doing the show on your
own with with your wife being the
cameraman can you do this for a year I
don't know man so much but I don't know
how much she totally bones hearing she's
actually being interviewed because if we
can't get guests you know I know my wife
you are quoted as saying the following
this is the greatest quote ever and this
is a quote I'm gonna remember after this
whole coronavirus thing is completely
over no you said doing the show without
an audience
I felt like Robert De Niro's character
and the King of Comedy it's impossible
it's impossible that's exactly what it's
like you all of a sudden especially
doing your show from your home
he's do his show from the basement
everyone to be quiet we do the jokes and
of course the kids aren't there messing
stuff up and just it's true it's totally
like little rascals let's put on a show
you